in this episode i interviewed benny
lewis
a polyglot someone who knows several
languages
he believes people can become fluent in
another language in three months
he's a best-selling author world
traveler and a pretty funny guy
i'm slowly struggling to learn russian
which i've been doing for a while
so i figured why not have this guy on
considering he seems pretty good at
learning languages
this episode is full of good information
remember to hit subscribe if you enjoy
this
episodes every sunday and wednesday this
episode is brought to you by
true local true local is the company i
get my meat from
i'm very picky about the quality of what
i eat because if you only eat one thing
and it doesn't taste good life would
suck you can go to tru
local.ca to make yourself a custom box
they have any meat you want plus some
organs
i like their grain-fed beef the best
lamb turkey
and wild salmon but i haven't tried any
of the spiced meat or pork
you can also get some vegetables on
there now too they connect with local
farmers and then ship you their stuff so
it's super simple for you
and it's great for keeping local farmers
working and getting people access to
high quality sustainably raised meat
tru local.ca code mp so trulocal knows
their investment into my podcast is
worth it i hope you enjoy this podcast
episode and learn something
[Music]
benny lewis welcome to my podcast thank
you so much for having me
i am so excited for this one i invited
you on because
i'm trying to learn russian my husband
is russian
and i'm hoping that if i just talk to
you then i'll just
know how to speak russian afterwards
which is probably an unrealistic
expectation but
here we go anyway can we start off by
you giving a brief introduction to my
audience about who you are and what it
is that you do
absolutely so i'm benny lewis from
ireland and i run fluent in three months
which is the
world's largest language learning blog
with uh two million visitors a month
and i published uh several books i
published for three months i published
language
hacking courses but having said all of
that
i could only speak english when i was in
my 20s i have a background
in electronic engineering and i got into
languages
late in life so my whole mission
is to encourage adults who want to get
into
language learning that they can do it
and of course to give them language
hacks
to help them to do it excellent
that's what i want language hacks uh so
i think i i found out about you a while
ago like a number of years ago and
and then my life got really crazy so i
didn't end up
learning more about your program but how
many languages can you speak now
fluently so by if you go by
fluently as in i can function
uh socially equivalent to how i would in
english
than six non-english languages
so this is from uh living in those
countries for
a while and then eventually finding a
way to learn the languages
before going to the countries and i've
also dabbled in a lot of i think i've
dabbled in maybe
20 other languages that i had gotten up
to
conversational levels but then lost it
through lack of maintenance
but nowadays there are six languages i
would confidently
be able to do something like maybe this
interview
in those languages okay and are any of
those languages with different alphabets
uh yeah so i've learned mandarin
to a conversational level i've learned
american sign language which does not
have
any spelling of course associated with
it
the languages i've learned to that don't
have the
um the same script that we would use
include
arabic and um
thai and a few other ones these are the
ones i got uh
like enough of a level that i could
function
with um patient people who i could
converse with in those countries
and japanese as well that has three
different writing systems
i dabbled into that generally my focus
tends to be
more on the spoken aspect so
i don't really give attention to the
written form
until i've reached a more advanced stage
in the language
okay so that's these are kind of the
things that i want to get into
um i learned i took french in so in
canada
you're supposed to learn french and you
have to start in grade four
and nobody knows french in canada
everyone takes french and nobody knows
french and the way they teach
is they get you to read
and conjugate and and memorize verbs
and then nobody can communicate and they
teach you france french too so if you go
to montreal you can't understand anybody
so it's kind of a disaster
uh so and and the important aspect of
language
is so that you can go into a store and
communicate with somebody or communicate
with somebody on the street
so you said you started off by going to
countries
and learning and now you can do it
without going to the country
so yes what did both of those situations
look like and what changed
so the first thing is uh people imagine
going to the country will solve your
problem
so the first language i really dived
into i did take german
and we take irish in school as well and
i
didn't have any success with those in my
teenage years
but after i graduated i decided to learn
spanish
and i moved to spain and unfortunately
that wasn't enough i
had this concept in my mind that i'd get
off the plane i'd
inhale spanish air and exhale
espanol you know and that didn't happen
because
six months into living in spain i still
couldn't speak spanish
i had gravitated towards
english-speaking communities
so moving to the country does not
actually solve the problem
what truly solves the problem is
immersion and a lot of people
know this but immersion is not the same
as going to the country so um
step one was to create immersion in
those countries
and then several years later nowadays i
create what i like to think of as
virtual immersion so even though now i'm
locked down in my house
i have several hours a day that i exist
through other languages
but initially like how did i get over
this learning curve well
i tried a lot of things i tried going to
group classes and
similar to what you described we had a a
very grammatically
um packed initial approach and that just
didn't work for me it didn't work for me
when i took german in school
and i tried lots of other things i tried
picking up el senor de los anillos the
lord of the rings
and i thought if i read this from front
cover to back to
cover i'll be fluent in spanish and it
took me weeks to get to page two
using a dictionary for every word that
was a waste time
what i decided to do uh after six months
was very simply to exclusively speak
in spanish and it sounds a little
counter-intuitive because like how can
you exclusively speak in one language
when you haven't even reached the point
that you could speak it yet
and this is one of the major lessons
that i've learned over these years and
one of my mantras for people who want to
get into languages
is you have to speak it from day one and
you have to find ways that you're truly
using that language
and initially i didn't know if this
would work for me because
my spanish was so terrible that i
sounded like tarzan
when i would say things like me want go
supermarket and it just it would be a
mess grammatically
i would feel maybe the other person
doesn't have patience form for me to
speak this way
um and a lot of this was just my own
self-doubt because realistically people
are very enthusiastic when you try to
speak their language
and in many places they're very
encouraging so
it's mostly getting over your own
inhibitions
and when i realized this i started to
get this momentum and it actually
happened to me
in one single day i had a eureka moment
i was two weeks into my
attempt to speak spanish and it was very
sluggish and difficult
and i was um i was pretty broke at the
time so
when i bought an electric toothbrush uh
it
the toothbrush broke after a few days
and i was furious because i
spent money on this that i couldn't
afford so i stormed into the supermarket
that i bought it from and i was ready to
demand
my refund and i realized that uh the
emotion of the moment meant i didn't
look up any words ahead of time so
i didn't know how to say toothbrush i
didn't know how to say broken
i i didn't know how to say refund so
despite that i used my bad spanish and i
was like
uh machina diente uh machine of teeth
uh mallows it's bad uh
dinero round trip
you know which didn't really make any
sense but
what absolutely the the penny dropped
for me when i
actually got a refund from somebody who
did not speak english
using that very choppy caveman spanish
i succeeded in this goal and that made
me realize that
communication is the key here it's not
about getting things right it's not
about
conjugating the verbs correctly because
you can communicate
if you know just enough to get by
initially
and then as you go you get more
confidence you build upon
more words and you can get around to all
those grammar
tables and such later and i i do
eventually study those
but at the beginning stages it's just
communication
and that is the the idea that's
transformed
the last almost 20 years of my life
because from that day on
i've been able to travel the world and
live in these other countries
i've spent most of the last 17 years not
speaking english
and i've had such rich experiences
and that's by not becoming a genius i
was not naturally born to speak
languages because i
barely passed my exams in school this
was by
embracing sounding like an idiot being
okay with that
and seeing that people don't judge you
for it you make a lot of progress very
quickly
and because of that you'll eventually
get to that fluency stage if you keep it
up
okay this is what i brought you on for
because
i knew that that's what you suggested
and it was just like that makes me so
uncomfortable
right i don't like sounding like i don't
know what i'm doing
and i've realized you know if you come
up to people who've just moved to canada
or don't understand english very well
and they're struggling in the
supermarket
it doesn't bother me to help them like
they're learning english
english is hard to learn like that's
totally fine you you go girl
right but being the person who
is struggling is just it's very anxiety
provoking
so the the idea is you immerse yourself
and you don't you take what you know and
you just
go forward yeah and like i understand
about the anxiety
and it's one reason why i like to turn
it on its head a little bit and
i tell people that when i start learning
a language my
goal is to make at least 200 mistakes a
day
and when you when you think about it
that way rather than my goal
is to sound like an eloquent uh you know
professional speaker who can talk about
epistemology in the language
no my goal is to make mistakes
then it's impossible to fail you know
when you think about it that way because
you can
just open your mouth say something
you'll make mistakes and
it's kind of like getting those mistakes
out of your system
and then i i understand the other end of
it that you would imagine you know in
the country you're talking to strangers
and such
so there's lots of ways that you can
reduce that anxiety
so eventually many years later i've been
now in the process of learning languages
entirely online
before i go to the country and when i do
that i can simplify things because
there's
a lot of ways you can get in touch with
native speakers
and i understand the anxiety of you know
if i was in another country and i walked
up to a stranger on the street
they don't have the time for me or they
don't know me or whatever
but i very simply just pay somebody to
deal with my mistakes
and that can be incredibly affordable
because you're dealing with
currency differences between you know
canadian dollars or us dollars
and maybe rupees or whatever the
currency is the country that
the teacher is based in and as long as
you have a rule that this
i don't actually hire teachers i like to
think of them as language facilitators
because i don't want to be taught a
language can't really be taught
it can only be lived and i i try to live
that language
even digitally i connect myself with a
speaker
and i do everything i possibly can to
avoid using
english and it's difficult like i i
definitely don't have
the easy way to learn a language the
easy way is to lay back and
have some audio playing the background
that you're barely paying attention to
that's the easy way but it's not very
effective the effective way
is painful you know it you will have
anxiety you'll feel like
i'm such an idiot and i and i feel that
way even somebody who's learned
as many languages as i have to this day
i'll have a language lesson
in a language i'm kicking off and i will
feel like an idiot
and i'll feel like oh you're such a
failure you're supposed to be this
successful language learner and i feel
that and that's just a natural part of
the process for everybody
how many hours per day like when you
when you try and
immerse yourself in a new language do
you do
everything in that language for a while
when you give people that three-month
time frame so it's it's difficult to
know like how long does it take to learn
a language especially because
i think back in my own experience with
german i spent five years
in high school learning german and i had
nothing to show for it
so it's difficult to imagine like how
much time does it take to learn a
language
and it really does depend more on the
hours
than on the days or the months that you
put into it so
you can put one hour a day in and make
significant progress
as long as that hour is as efficient as
it possibly can and
ideally like you are speaking to a real
live
person as frequently as possible at
least a few times a week if you can
and that like that's that turns things
on its head because most people when
they think of language learning
they imagine going through books and
going through
apps for several months and then maybe i
don't know six months from now
then the magical moment will arrive
you'll have your you'll suddenly be
ready
you will never be ready and like i
always tell people this that even in the
languages
i have what's in europe we have the
european common framework
that's the grades your language level
and i've got a c2 diploma this is
mastery level
and i've reached this level but even
then there's obviously still going to be
words and dialect
uh terms in different countries and
specialization
that i haven't come across so i can
never say
i have finished learning spanish there's
always going to be more
there for me so i i turned that
backwards and i say
that means that it's okay that i don't
know anything at the start
and if you keep that in mind it's it's a
lot less intimidating
and on top of that you remember that
this is how children learn as well
that we're we're patient with them we
let them make mistakes
they they make grammatical errors when
they're speaking and
we encourage them and this this is the
reason children tend to learn languages
is because they're learning by trying i
always imagine you know
the analogy of how a lot of us learn a
language as adults
it's like if you were to learn how to
ride a bike by studying aerodynamics
and things like that rather than putting
your ass on this
on a saddle and just pedaling you know
that's and falling over
and that's kind of that analogy really
does
uh play in language learning that you
just have to do it
just have to be speaking with people
okay okay that totally makes sense
because
well that's how you learn language as a
kid so for
for children um my my daughter's
bilingual so she's russian
and english and i'm like how many how
many languages could i
introduce she's only three and a half
it's like how many languages could i
introduce
if she now without confusing her
i was like mandarin is one of those
language languages that perhaps people
should know
right like that might be a useful
language to know
um so i was like i wonder if i can
introduce you know a babysitter or
somebody who comes
fairly often who speaks mandarin but
would that amount of information confuse
her because russian and english are very
different and then
mandarin's very different and i'm like
she's not
she's three and a half so she's not
fluent in all them but i was like how
much can one brain handle
so do you think two questions do you
think kids how much do you think kids
can handle for languages and then
when you're an adult say in your 20s or
past
should you be free you should probably
be focusing on one at a time right
yeah so to adjust the children side of
things um
you know as like yourself i'm a native
english speaker
and native english speakers have a a
particular perspective on the world
that is a little flawed because we
imagine that speaking one language is
the norm but
actually over 50 percent of the world
speaks multiple languages
and this is not because of genetics it's
not because if you have
certain skin color you're more you're
you have the language gene or something
this is just because
they grow up needing to use multiple
languages
so um i have friends of mine that have
actively tried to
teach their children to speak multiple
languages and a few of them have
children who can speak
six languages and i wow
i absolutely believe that this is not
because they were born with the magical
language gene
it's because the parents just decided
they wanted to
have a multilingual environment and like
you said they had babysitters
who might speak one language one parent
will speak one language to them the
other will speak another
they'll send them to a particular
language school maybe every summer
they'll send them to a language
uh a summer camp that kind of
uh gears around one language there's a
lot of things you can do
and generally you they you just need
exposure to the language i don't know
what the upper limit is like
i i i don't think necessarily that's as
useful a question just that
if there are particular languages you
truly care about
you can make the environment uh con
conductive
to uh like it's interesting and it's fun
and that's something that's me that was
missing for a lot of us like was missing
for you
when you grew up with french because it
just had this very
academic feel to it like you know that
made you
resist it and think like why would i
want to learn french and in ireland we
start learning the irish language
galga at age six and i had that same
resistance because it was purely
grammatical
and as an adult i came back to that
language
and i had the perspective of i have
friends in this language
that i want to communicate with i want
to hang out with i want to go to the pub
with whatever it is
and if with your children if you're just
you know putting a a language show on
the tv or something then
maybe they'll care about it but if
you're giving opportunities to have
friendships or if they if they have
relationships are really what languages
are built around
so if they have some form of a
relationship with somebody that'll make
the language
a real thing and i think for a lot of us
languages just are this
uh purely theoretical academic thing in
our heads
you know yeah that's a really good point
if you need to communicate with somebody
otherwise what's the point
i actually enjoyed french in school i
even liked the grammar lessons
but that's also because i was like well
if i memorize this
i'll get better at speaking french and
so eventually it was like well this
isn't working at all but
i didn't mind the grammar okay what
happens uh what happens if
it's a completely different language
it's a completely different alphabet
do you get people to learn the alphabet
near the beginning or
immerse themselves in any kind of
written language or do you say
really just focus on communicating or
how do you get people to learn like
the minimal amount of words like is
there any memorizing
in that way yeah so the um
it depends on the language so for
something like
chinese the the chinese writing system
or the kanji in japanese generally and
and a lot of people won't agree with me
on this in the language learning space
but generally
i would say it's a waste of time to
learn that initially
you want to be able to phonetically
represent the language now this doesn't
mean
learning how to write chinese or
japanese is a waste of time it just
means that
you want to follow a similar pattern to
how chinese and japanese children learn
the language they all learned
the spoken language first and then they
learned the written language
and i got around to learning the hansa
the written form of chinese
after i finally reached a conversational
level in mandarin
and it was so much easier because i had
the context to it
now that's for those very different
languages for a language like russian
or many other languages that have uh
phonetic scripts to them
so this is like uh just an alternative
alphabet
it's really not that bad to learn it
quickly and
the alphabets i've learned phonetically
like if you get a any course so with
russian i
happen to have this one here that
somebody loaned me
just read and write russian script um or
there's another one a friend of mine
wrote a series on script hacking
so you get russian script hacking and
i've used
these kinds of books in learning these
other languages and you're just
you're just learning 26 letters you know
or
something along the that number maybe
they add a couple
depending on the the language but you
can learn that quickly
and then you can recognize it takes a
little bit of
time that you'll start to see words and
there are techniques that will help you
like if you focus more on cognates it'll
show you words you already know
then you see the letters and it'll help
you to
produce them a bit more quickly and with
time you'll be able to recognize those
letters that's that's
not a lot of work you know it's a little
bit of work up front
but then after that what you can do for
your vocabulary is you can just see the
word written
as it's supposed to be now with mandarin
i would say to do this with pinyin which
they do
use in china as well to kind of
represent the sound this is just
the phonetic version of how things are
set in mandarin
and then for japanese they have hiragana
and katakana
and these are their own writing systems
but they're also phonetic
so they're not a different character for
every word
like uh you would have with the uh the
kanji that is more typically
thought of when you think of a lot of
japanese but
these are are things you can do in very
short spaces of time
you can learn these writing systems and
then when you come across vocabulary
you'll pronounce it as it's supposed to
be pronounced and it'll also remove
the bias that we have uh with english
characters that
you you know like when i was learning
arabic script for instance
i when i used the romanized
version i had this bias of wanting to
pronounce it like was an english word or
maybe another european language word but
it just
you have a slightly better um mapping of
each sound
to the right character when you use
their writing system so even though
i'm all about speaking i'm also about
the pareto principle
you know you do the 20 of the work that
gives you 80
of the results and in terms of learning
the writing system
that's a 20 thing that's not that much
work it can feel intimidating
but as long as you're using a pretty
decent system you'll
be able to read it within no time and
then how you actually acquire the
vocabulary
that's another thing that i personally
failed on when i was in school is i
would see a list of words
and i would just think i need to
regurgitate that through wrote
and i would just repeat it over and over
and over again
and people imagine to be a successful
language learner
you need to have a super memory you know
and i
i forget where i put my keys all the
time i forget people's names when they
introduce themselves to me
i am not one of those naturally born
geniuses
and yet i am able to speak a complex
language with many thousands of words
because i've found other ways to learn
the uh vocabulary quicker i've used
mnemonics you know
so for instance with french you come
across a word for train station like
and you think okay it sounds like gar or
garfield i'll imagine garfield the cat
is
running through a train station to catch
a train to the lasagna eating
competition of the world you come up
with some crazy mnemonic
and okay it's the great thing about that
is
uh it's symmetrical because a lot of
people will say
i can kind of read the language when i
see it on paper i'll see a word
and i know what that means but when i
have to produce it then i can't i don't
know how to say it
and the great thing about mnemonics is
that it is symmetrical because you'll
see
written down you'll be like oh i know
that that's train station but you'd also
be
speaking and you'll need to say train
station you'd be like okay
what was in the train station oh
garfield the cat it's it's gah
and that'll kind of kick you think kick
you off and these mnemonics
it seems very complicated to think about
that every time
but the great thing is i found when i
use these mnemonics
is that i'll need to reference them two
or three times
and then i just know the word so even
though i came up with that mnemonic when
i was first learning french
whatever 15 16 years ago i
i did have to use it a couple of times
but now i just
know what the word for train station is
i don't need
to do any mental gymnastics it's a
crutch
that helps you get there quicker so
that's one thing i want to say about
vocab is
you can get into it in mnemonics the
other thing
is um is that you do need repetition
so another thing we imagine that's very
intimidating
is you'll see a word and if i test you
on that word like a minute later
and you know it you think okay great i
should know this word forever
yeah and then if i test you on it
tomorrow and you've forgotten you think
oh man i'm such an idiot
how could i forget this word and people
have to realize this is
absolutely natural we need repeated
exposure the same way
children when they're learning languages
they need repeated exposure to the word
the trick is to find out what is the
ideal algorithm and there people have
written about this using the spaced
repetition system
that effectively you can use and this is
built into a lot of apps nowadays my
favorite one is
anki amki anki's the best i'll just
i have an uh a google sheet
open during my language lesson and i'll
fill that up with all the new
vocabulary i've learned and then
afterwards i'll export that to anki
and anki of course as you know since you
use it it'll
say you know show this a day later or a
week later
and that is the reason that people
think they don't know they think they're
bad at vocabulary because
firstly they don't know how to remember
it that first time and secondly
they will naturally forget it a week
later and they'll think therefore i'm
bad at language learning but
that's that's just a part of the process
you just need that repeat
exposure and something like anki gives
you flash cards in a
more systematic way that you will see it
just before you're likely to forget it
and then there's an
exponential curve that stretches out
that the next time you need to be
reminded
is much much later and then if you're
naturally because anki is a more of an
artificial way but if you're naturally
speaking the language with a teacher
face to face
and expanding that to doing other things
like you know i'll
i'll listen like while i can't travel i
listen to
live streamed radio from the country and
i'll try to sing along to the songs and
i might find
articles online that i might want to
read i wouldn't really do reading at the
very beginning i'd
wait until my intermediate stage for
that but all of these things are
reinforcing
those vocabulary words in a more natural
way
so that those are the two things i'd say
about memorization that
we can feel like we're just not we're
just not built for this
but we've if you are understanding this
podcast
you have the language gene because
you've already learned
at least one language successfully it's
just a case of applying that process
to the next language yeah for english p
through the english language too it has
so many words
and so many random rules like compared
to learning something like i learned
quite a bit of french
just not enough to get me over the hump
or maybe i'm just not brave enough to
start speaking it
but compared to french it seems like a
more difficult
language to learn right off the bat and
i've heard that from
immigrants coming being like english is
more difficult has
more words it's got a random structure
like so if you've learned english
there's probably hope
that that's a very interesting way of
learning so that sounds kind of
like how i memorized a lot of
information
or learned a lot of information in
science because there would be these
scientific terms and i'd be like how on
earth am i going to remember that and
i'd take part of the word
and associate it with something very
random loose associations
ideally something that made me kind of
giggle like why on earth would i
associate those two things
and then i'd remember the term from that
and i used anki but i was using it
badly i didn't realize that you could
just
export out of excel and import i was
just using the app it took forever
ugh that's going to change my life okay
so jump right in and just start speaking
so the way we're taught to learn how to
conjugate and learn how to write first
is just
backwards and that's why it's so hard
for people because it's not like how
children learn
yeah and i i'm i'm not going to say like
go burn your grammar books because
here's the thing like i said german was
the language i learned in school
and i found it uninteresting unlike you
i just
had no interest in the language i didn't
find it fun
but then when i got back into it later
and i started having friendships in
german
and i reached i reached the basic
conversational stage
then i opened up a grammar book and
something crazy happened like
from someone who really refused to to
learn grammar and hated it
i would open up the grammar book and it
would be like reading a novel because i
i would see a rule and i'd be like
that's why they say it that way and it
would just like
be this amazing putting the pieces of
the puzzle together
so i i think a lot of traditional
learning approaches
are very useful actually and i will use
uh traditional language courses in the
intermediate stages to have all those
exercises and stuff
and such but that's much better when
you have something to piece together
because a grammar
rule by itself when you're starting
you've nothing to stick that to
yeah and this is why you just got to
throw yourself into the language
sound like a caveman for a while be okay
with that
and eventually you'll you'll have enough
caveman speech
that you'll have had exposure to the
language that you'll naturally start to
learn to learn
the the words by osmosis the the rules
naturally
and then you can start to do it in a
more systematic approach
to tidy things up and i i prefer to have
this
chaos first approach and tidy things up
later
and i know that can be very intimidating
for a lot of people
but this is why i say if you do things
like simply
some teachers online are just ten
dollars an hour when
you're getting them from their own
country and they're earning very good
money there
and i'm okay with like maybe it takes me
like 30 seconds
that i have to open up a new tab and i
have to search for the word because i
really don't want to say it in english
and my teacher just has to sit there
patiently and that's an artificial
situation i would not put a stranger on
the street through
and that's okay because as long as
you're staying in that language
i'm getting my momentum i'm getting my
confidence and then it means when i do
go to the country
i can have those exchanges so much more
confidently
okay i considered doing that because
there are a lot of russian
language teachers online and a lot of
them are just conversations that you
have with somebody
and it's cheap if you're converting
currency and it's a good deal for
everybody
i considered that and i was like i don't
know how much
what what happens if you're if you have
a full-time job
and you're really busy and you can only
do
so what would one even one hour a day is
a lot for
a conversation in another language but
how long do you think it takes to
get fluent if you're conversing with
somebody or attempting to
for an hour a day well you wouldn't
necessarily need to make the
if you only have one hour you need don't
need to have it just
one hour of conversing because that
doesn't give you
time to absorb the information generally
i like to have my conversation
and then after it that will direct with
the study i'm doing and i might see
you know what i don't know how to say
basic verbs like to eat to sleep
i'm going to go research that i'm going
to create an anki deck or find one
online and i'm going to study that
so i if your time is tight just do half
hour lessons or even shorter time for
the
half hour if you have to um if you just
have an hour a day it's very difficult
to say
how long it will take to get fluent
because it depends on so many factors of
that person's learning experience
and i think i'm i'm at a stage now where
i can learn a language very quickly
and it's not necessarily because i'm
smarter
than i was 20 years ago when i was
failing
i think it's because i embrace mistakes
a lot more
so i've learned through doing it so many
times that i
it's okay to sound a little bit like an
idiot
and to to have super basic conversations
as long as i'm just i i have to have
those conversations for a few weeks
and then a little bit later i can start
to talk about things that are important
to me
and it does require that amount of
patience and that completely transforms
your experience
and it's why it's very hard for me to
say well one hour a day therefore nine
months later you'll be fluent because
there
there is no real equation there's no
formula i can put in that'll
kick things out at the other end from
that and
like my my blog my book they have the
title flu in three months
and the reason for that is actually
because that's been
my personal projects that i give myself
these goals and like a way of thinking
is another way i could have titled
the book or blog is specific project in
specific time
and here's an example that works for me
so
i think a big mistake a lot of people
make like you know just uh
recently we had the new year people will
have new year's resolutions
i'm gonna learn spanish and it's
something i'm sure it's come up in the
podcast a million times is
smart goals you know specific measurable
and all that stuff
so i try to have uh when i have a
language project i
i don't decide i'm just going to learn
spanish i'm going to try to get to
basic conversational within two months
so that i can
make at least one friend on this trip to
spain as an example
so i try to have that very specific goal
and
everything about my project is tailored
to that in mind and that means that
i'm not going to study grammar books
because the goal is not pass a grammar
exam
you know everything is about these
conversations and that and
it means that if you're having daily
conversations not only are you focusing
on the thing you need to focus on but it
means in the other
half an hour or hopefully you have a
little bit more time
that you're able to put into like
studying the language or like
structuring fixing the problems that you
had you're doing it based on those
spoken sessions
so rather than a language course that
says here's unit one here's unit two
you're kind of structuring your own
system or a little bit less intimidating
you're structuring it with your teacher
or your language facilitator
who's guiding you in that process once
you share your goals
and then it becomes a lot more realistic
and this is why i think
in a matter of months people can get
to conversational stage and personally i
can get to the
fluency stage where like i said social
equivalency
there's still more to learn it's not
perfect perfectionism
but i can get to social equivalency in a
span of a few months
mainly not because i'm smart but because
i embrace the fact that i'm stupid if
that makes any sense
i'm okay with that okay with sounding
like an idiot i get that out of my
system
and then very quickly i start to get
confidence and be able to express myself
in much more complex topics is it
dependent on the language you're
learning
are some of them easier and some of them
more difficult it's a very good question
i get that very
very often and people imagine one
language to be easier than the other but
my my answer is a little
counter-intuitive for people because
when you ask me what's the hardest
language i've learned and i think
you know i've i've dabbled in hungarian
i've learned quechua the inca language
like i said i've done several asian
languages the hardest language i've ever
learned
was spanish because that's the language
that i had
the worst approach for it this is the
language i needed to really polish
things up for
this is the language i had absolutely no
confidence and i
falsely believed that every time i spoke
that i'm
making these people angry and that
they're laughing at me
and like how dare i i i i don't deserve
to speak spanish
and that means it took me a year to get
to the same
level of conversational ability in
spanish that it took me to get to in
mandarin in three months
and it's it's in large part because i
changed my attitude and of course i had
improved my learning
approach with better techniques so it
really depends
and i know it's very easy to compare
languages side by side and say well you
know what german has more
grammar or chinese has tones and decide
therefore
this language is harder than this one
but like my
experience in talking to actual people
doing these things has been very
different like
as an example when i was in spain i met
a spaniard who
was learning both french and japanese
and and i was like oh wow you know
japanese must be so hard and he's like
no french is harder
and the reason was he didn't care about
french he just had to do it for school
and you know i i talked down to french a
lot but i've actually
spent a while in canada i learned jouel
this is the
montreal dialect of french so i love
french but anyway
this guy he just didn't care for french
but he had a he had a thing for japanese
girls and
for kanji and whatever and that
transformed his japanese experience that
it became
easier because he had the passion for it
and
this real world context like as well as
being a more efficient approach
to talk to a human being it also changes
your motivation in the language
because like for a lot of us language
learning is this really theoretical
concept when i was learning german
in school before i had that experience
of having friendships in berlin
to me german was just this robotic
like i imagine everyone in germany would
just go through
in like like robots processing daddy das
cases
and in going to germany i find that
they're actually way more
uh way more fun to be around than a lot
of other cultures in a lot of ways
i love germans and they're the most
personal people in the world
but as a teenager i imagine they were
all robots like who would want to learn
german
if it's just all this grammar and
obviously a language is more to
more than that so when you change your
context
and you try to make friendships in the
language and
try to speak it that changes your
motivation and that automatically even
forgetting
that it's a more efficient learning
approach that motivation change
automatically makes it easier than any
other language you could learn so
the the concept of comparing languages
to me
is is completely devoid of this personal
connection
and that's what makes a language hard or
easy
okay that that definitely makes sense to
me i think also maybe
the way of learning it by forming
relationships and speaking to other
people makes them more similar
than starting with the alphabet because
then you look at something like mandarin
and you think
there's no way that's so different but
maybe if you start
by trying to speak to other people there
are more similarities
yeah and on top of that your approach uh
and
mentality changes a lot because it's
very easy to take a language like
mandarin and say
it's just the hardest language in the
world because of this you know it's got
the writing system it's got tones
but i've gone out of my out of my way to
to write like
articles and even ebooks and such about
why mandarin is easy
why hungarian is easy because you can
you could turn that on its head mandarin
does not have a very complex
grammar system has very simple sound
structures that you can learn
very fast and there's a lot of things
that are working for
the spoken language even if the written
language definitely has
a lot of challenges spoken language
isn't that bad
and if you give me any language i can
argue for you
why that language is easy it doesn't
have all these other things
from other languages and of course
somebody can come back to me and say
oh yeah well here's why it's hard and i
personally i don't find that useful
because for me
motivation is so central to a language
that yes if it has complex grammar that
is something you have to deal with
but you can you can work around that so
i haven't learned russian but i have
learned
some czech another slavic language and
something you'll hear about slavic
languages is
the grammar is so complicated and
yeah the grammar is complicated but it's
actually very logical these slavic
languages
um balance out that grammar issue with
the vocab issue
vocabulary is very very easy because
they
build upon words a lot easier than we do
in a language like english that
each word can kind of feel random but in
slavic languages they add
uh suffixes and prefixes to the word and
that kind of builds it up in a way that
if you have
more limited vocabulary you'll recognize
more complicated words a lot quicker
and then on top of that yeah okay the
grammar is complicated but
you don't have to worry about that as a
beginner the like um
with slavic languages you have the
nominative case which
is the word you'll see in the dictionary
when you look it up
and when you speak it you have to apply
grammatical cases to it
and i say as a beginner who cares yeah
okay i will just
i'll just use the the dictionary form
they know what i'm saying
yes it doesn't sound great but this is
just
this is what language hacking is it's
okay with not sounding
eloquent and you'll fix it later okay
when i i was in russia for about seven
weeks last year and
it i was getting really irritated at not
being able to speak or understand people
and i ended up
because i was so immersed in it i ended
up understanding a lot more than i i was
surprising how much i could understand
fairly
fairly
quickly and so i started to try and
speak
and i was with my husband hopefully he
can't hear me right now
and he was saying oh you know that's not
quite right at the end and things and i
remember just being like
look i don't know how to speak russian
i'm just going to say the part of the
word i get
and then just the next word that i kind
of get and if they're all in
different conjugations i think people
will understand me anyway
yeah like that's how kids talk like i
know it sounds stupid but like
i get it when people talk like that so
they're gonna get me and i'll figure it
out eventually
and one thing i would recommend for you
in your case because you
your husband speaks the language and you
have a very deep relationship with him
that's that's a wonderful thing but it's
actually not
ideal for a language learning situation
so whenever i meet couples who want to
learn one another's language
i what i found is more effective is if
they do the vast majority of their work
with somebody else it's not actually
that practical
for your husband to teach you russian
because he's so used to talking to you
in complex ways in english that
if if he hears you speak russian that
that adjustment is a very difficult
thing but like i said languages are
about
relationships so what you need is you
need to start
a new relationship with the language
teacher and
that relationship exists 100 percent
exclusively in russian
and then in your brain you start to
develop the this
this um back this concept in the back of
your mind
that i need to use russian to
communicate with this teacher
and that helps the language flow whereas
with your husband
you don't need to use russian because
you can switch back to english
yeah but even with the russian teacher
who speaks english
you can kind of trick your subconscious
a lot if you just avoid
ever using english with them and this
gives you that
that sense of immersion that the reason
that immersion works for a lot of people
again it's not because they're in the
country it's because of that necessity
that forces them to just push through
the fact that at the beginning
stages are difficult you don't have that
necessity with your husband so i would
recommend
you have russian teachers focus on them
and then maybe you'll eventually be able
to speak russian with your husband but
that's
not something you want to be worrying
about right now because that that's
going to
be messy with the current dynamics you
have in your relationship you know
so begin a new relationship it makes me
angry at him
me not speaking well makes me angry at
him
and i can imagine like as you said he'll
correct you on the little things and
and like you know you just you need
somebody who's just going to put up with
those little mistakes
and some like when i'm choosing a
teacher some teachers
are very quick to correct and that is
useful for me
at an intermediate stage that's the
stage when i need those corrections
but at the beginning stages i will be
very quick to just decide you know what
this teacher isn't working for me and i
would recommend anybody listening who
has
tried to learn a language in the past
and run into one of these
the these brick walls that the person
you've spoken to
kind of cut you off they made you feel
bad this does not mean you are a bad
language learner
this means what you did didn't work for
you whether that was the course you
worked
with or the teacher you used so i
have no guilt whatsoever and saying this
teacher sucks
cancel get the next teacher you know and
that's the way we have to look at it you
have to find the approach that is
benefiting you
and in your case with your husband
that's that's not a dynamic that's going
to going to work
for your russian learning but you know
you can find a new
um a new teacher who you can build a
russian relationship
with that eventually may allow you to
speak to your husband
after you've gone through the stage that
isn't as ideal to speak with him
yeah yeah okay that totally makes sense
uh i had my kid
so my kid speaks russian and she was
trying to teach me some russian words i
was like teach me some russian words
so she started with a russian word i
can't remember what it was and then she
she's not even useful she goes pla pla
and i was like like i know that's not a
russian word i was like what does that
mean
and she just made something up i can't
remember what she means like it means
lost and i was like no it doesn't why
are you teaching
mom fake russian words she was just like
because it's
funny it's very funny she's three and a
half and i was like
oh my god what have i created but
uh that's all really good information
can we end this by you telling
me and the audience what did what
exactly you
offer for people for helping people
learn languages
yeah absolutely so uh firstly i have a
podcast as well the language hacking
podcast if you tune into that
you'll hear very encouraging stories of
other people
and what's worked for them from a range
of backgrounds
um i've also got um a private
community that i coach people to
learning a language
to at least a conversation level in
three months so that's the fluent in
three months challenge
and otherwise i got loads of free advice
if you sign up to my email list i'll
give you a
speak in a week crash course with the
best tips initially
and i published a bunch of books i have
language hacking spanish
french italian and german i have float
in three months as my own book
and i'm on social media all the time
trying to share my own language learning
uh things and to show people the real
side of language learning that i kind of
want
this idea of me as a polyglot that i'm
not impressive i don't want people to
think i'm smart i want people to be able
to do
what i've done because anyone can do it
it's just a case of finding the right
approach
and i'm hoping my advice will help you
out with that so
fluent in three months or irish polyglot
do a search for those or language
hacking podcast
thank you i think it's impressive
regardless uh i remember i was in
you mentioned how people around the
world speak multiple languages and it's
really just english people that think
no it's just one language you know per
person and i was in switzerland
and i was in a cab or an uber i was in
an uber
and he was talking to me and then he had
two phone calls and each phone call was
in a different language and i was like
how many languages do you speak and he's
like oh he's six fluently
and he's an uber driver in switzerland
and he's like how many do you speak and
it was just like
one he was like oh it's like yeah that's
you know it's not just me i swear it's
not just me
but thank you thank you very much for
coming on that was really interesting
uh and best of luck with your russian
and i re i really hope i've shown you
that
you absolutely can learn it i've i
started
in my 20s and now i'm i'm a polyglot and
a lot of people
who follow my stuff have started much
much later in life and they've succeeded
so it's never too late to learn a
language that is
so cool thank you very much thank you
you